it's
interesting i was going to give you uh
three books uh
i i noted the accent when i met you but
i didn't know exactly where you're from
but the the other book i was going to
say is dostoevsky's crime and punishment
and i mean i've always wanted to go to
saint pete's uh
just to sort of see with my own eyes
what the word pictures that uh
dostoevsky created
in a crime and punishment and you know i
love others of this stuff
too the brothers care myself and so
forth but crime and punishment i first
read
in high school as a junior or senior and
it is a
deep and profound uh meditation
on uh the the both the meaning and the
measure
of our lives and uh uh
dostoevsky uh obviously in in
in conversation with other uh thinkers
um uh really gets at the
uh the the crux of
a fundamental philosophical problem what
does it mean to be a human being
and and
for that crime and punishment captured
me as a teenager and that's another text
that i returned to uh often
you